when you want to make some serious
connections with your customers you need
to use
print
[Music]
i run my own business and i run my own
studio and if you want to know a little
secret about graphic design
and what your clients want from you it's
not good design
they want to see results and ideally
they want to make money from those
results
then they come back they don't mind
paying you for that so how are you going
to get those results for your clients
how do you get clients to keep coming
back to you because you
give great results i believe print is
the answer
not only making digital campaigns just
getting out of that clutter and making
sensory connections
you will see massive results for both
you and your client
so i want you to start thinking
differently i want to thank
you to think how can you
get in touch with your customers are
there places
in their journey where you could make
some physical connections
because those connections have
massive results if you can contact more
than three
of the senses you're going to be
remembered
70 more it's a wonderful way to get
additional
income for your business it creates that
ongoing work
that we're always looking for as
designers i've been running my own
studio for 17 years and i could not
imagine
not having clients return for print work
not only does it bring them back to you
when they need more reprints
it creates extra income when you're
making a markup on the print
it's a wonderful way to generate
an ongoing income for your business
when we're starting off deciding what
printer to use
we've got to know the right questions to
ask one
if we're doing it for ourselves we need
to know what size
what we're expecting what stock options
now
you don't have to know the answers to
these because some of them will be
dependent on price
and also once you know them you can
actually change your designs
depending on price you'll know if
there's limitations
on what you have to design so it's
definitely worth getting
a print quote before you do projects
you don't want to get carried away
designing spots and finishes that are
not going to be affordable for your
client
then they're going to be disappointed
with the results and think oh i wish i
had that
so make sure when you start
you find out from your client what do
they need
why do they need it what are they
thinking of
what do you think would be the best
solution
how are they going to be stored that's
important because if they are big bulky
brochure and you have a thousand of them
it's important for us to know
where they're going to put them and also
where they're going to store them
before delivery so do check that out can
they be delivered direct from the
printer
or does a client have somewhere they can
put those
for you then we will go online and have
a look at some printing options
if you're thinking at that point in time
you need a foil
have a look some key words i realized it
was hard today when i
googled in how to find a printer you've
got a big problem because there's
printers
that actually print into people's
offices that is causing problems
so the things we're typing in is how to
find short run printing
how to find printers for packaging have
a look online i have got a list of
resources please get in touch with me
and i'll also put a list of resources
out there that will help you
find the right printers for you when it
comes to getting the right results for
your print
jobs knowledge is the key the more we
understand about the process
the more information we have the more we
can make the right decisions so we get
brilliant results and we're happy with
the results at the end
during a time when everything's online
having something we can
touch and feel it's almost magical
i get just a little bit too excited when
i'm stroking
a spot of gloss on the front of a book
or i'm getting to open that apple
package for the first time
i'm feeling the excitement and the joy
it's such an amazing feeling the sensory
moment
so join me and learn how to get physical
with print i want you to feel
confident i want you to have great
results for you and your clients
you